good morning believe nation if Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is solve big problems over to
you Jack Ma we are not a company that
normally China : we call ourselves a
companies running a platform a company
that is running an ecosystem we are
almost everywhere people say Jack you
know you are in the b2b b2c and you're
calling CTV on a finance and online
payment logistic cloud computing you are
everywhere not because we're greedy not
because we want to do it because we have
to do it if we cannot if we do not to do
it
China ecommerce in the years will
collapse
I remember nine years ago when I started
that a leap a people say get don't touch
the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison and I we
taught our self if we don't do it the
China newcomers were always like a like
a chat room everybody said it's a good
thing and yeah I don't pay you don't get
the things so say well put me in the
prison let's make sure that Ali pay the
payment solution works and people say
the payment solution such a stupid idea
is the escrow service
I tell you hold the money and you get
the things you pay the money if you
don't get the things you want return the
money
they said it's a stupid product and I
say as long as I solve the problem I
like stupid things you know let's make
stupid things smart keep on improving
every day today we have over 800 million
people register using a leap a esta
count and a leap in up today solve the
ecommerce problems we are paying the
electricity water bill and even taxi and
last week I went to a vegetable market
somebody say we accept Ali pay it goes
they say all you pay with you know if
they get the force money and the
allottee can solve that problem so we
are actually building up a
infrastructure of China it's hard to
stay motivated when you're solving small
problems at least for me I have a really
hard time staying motivated staying
engaged if I see the problem is just
really small and tiny
I had a call yesterday with a youtuber
who has a successful channel but hasn't
posted in almost a year and now you know
she wants to get back and back on the
horse and keep posting more videos and
she's so concerned about what happens in
that first video you know she has a plan
to make more videos but all she's
wrapped up in is what do I do with this
first video and it's important you know
to figure out what happens in that first
video but much more important is what's
the consistent plan right if you want to
have success on YouTube it's about
making regular videos like how are you
going to get to weekly videos and then
multiple times a week and then daily
like the long tail the long term is so
much more important than what happens in
this one specific video because how many
your subscriber is going to watch it and
you know it's just it's just not as
important and so for me I hate focusing
on the little things when there's a much
bigger problem to focus on she really
should be focusing on okay I'll make a
first video it doesn't really matter
like any single video I put up on my
channel it doesn't really matter it
doesn't really have a huge impact its
accumulation that's every single video
and so I want to focus on the big things
I want to focus on the big problems I
want to solve that and not just this
little tiny thing and so it's why I want
to help a billion entrepreneurs you know
it's a it's a motivating it's an
inspiring goal I like helping
entrepreneurs one on one it gives me a
lot of great personal enjoyment Attis
faction but I want to have a big impact
I know I can have a bigger impact if you
have the ability you have the
responsibility and so that that wakes me
up energized to go out and try to do
something when I'm coming here making
these videos for you I'm imagining that
I'm speaking to a million people and I
hope this message gets through because I
I have a big impact and so when you work
on big problems your motive is such as
entrepreneurs like you want to do
something bigger we have that mind to
want to go out and have a huge impact
and so we we hate working on these
little tiny small problems the flip side
though sometimes is it can be too big
and I remember having this where I
thought can I actually help a billion
entrepreneurs can I actually change the
world like it's a noble thing but can I
actually go and do it and sometimes your
goal can be too big and may even depend
on the day to be honest some days you
wake up and you're motivate and ready to
go do it and some days you wake up to
Who am I to be able to go off and have
that big of an impact and so it's
finding where's the edge of your comfort
zone what's a goal that's big enough to
push you to say that's just beyond
achievable like if I push myself hard I
can go and do that I might be edging my
comfort zone because if it's too easy
you're not going to move ated to do it
you're going to be bored you're going to
feel like it's a waste of your time
waste your talent and you're not going
to be engaged in it and if it's too big
or too hard you're also not going to be
motivated to do it because it's
impossible so we're going to get done
and so finally what that goal is at the
edge of your comfort zone solving a big
problem that is meaningful to you that
is impactful to you but makes you feel
valuable if you can grow it and reach it
and solve it and help people I think
it's really really really important
entrepreneurs and I'd be looking at
yourself your life your business if you
don't feel challenged if you feel bored
if you're not growing it's probably
because you are not solving a big enough
problem right now so the question today
today is I'm curious what is the big
problem that you want to solve right now
with your business leave it down in the
comments below really curious to find
out and also if you're leaving a comment
within the first couple hours of this
video going live you have a chance to
win one or two daily prizes I also want
to give a quick shout out to Paul Benoit
Dubois then thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word I really really really appreciate
it and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning another shot of
espresso Oh
forgive me
pravin the brilliant formula is simple
what makes a successful person they go
out and solve big problems so you know
how to make a billion dollars
you follow ten billion dollar problem
having already made his billions you now
unashamedly wants to use his business
brain to change our world let's focus on
education health care energy shortage of
water shortage of food and I'm going to
tell you how innovation and
entrepreneurship can solve each of these
problems let's look at education imagine
if you are able to use is $25 tablet and
build some type of a game that's more
effective than a private teacher and
it's more addictive than the most
addictive video game think about it one
day a child is going to come to the
mother in six mom can I just play one
more hour of math because I enjoy so
much Devine has a knack of putting
people under his spell making his
mission to solve some of mankind's
biggest problems seem plausible in space
and on earth what if we can build an
artificial intelligence system that can
be used by a village girl she'll be able
to go door to door and able to diagnose
the diseases that there are no health
care there's no hospital there are no
doctor these are big only D is it could
turn a big profit but some of them seem
a bit far-fetched what if we take a 3d
printer on the moon and somebody can go
out and send the DNA of a bacteria or a
virus and we printed right there and
leave it in the moon and watch it go do
some ideas they're a bit out there on
tiny baby don't people think you're just
a bit mad what the point is that the
reason they think is mad because it's
already they don't know it's already
happening things that used to be science
fiction are now becoming sighs reality
and I think for all of you there are
many areas where there's leverage
available in the world where you know
one or two people a good idea a lot of
hard work can really make a difference
there's many many things like that and
it's good not to forget that but it's
good to look for those things
googles mission is to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful and
one of the things that surprised me
that's a very broad mission it's a lot
of work we're not going to achieve at
anytime soon right it's almost an
impossible task but it's an exciting
task and one that you can get other
people excited about and they can help
you and one of the things that I'll
surprise me is sometimes easier to do
something that's harder because other
people get excited about it and you can
get much more resource you can get
tremendous resources to solve a hard
problem whereas you might only get minor
resources just hauls a small problem my
I like to say my management style is
problem solver in chief and so what I do
in a given day is I have a set of
problems that need to be solved and I
started the most important and work my
way down and for the problems I don't
have time for somebody else gets to
solve them now if somebody is already
solving another problem of solving a
problem I don't need to get involved if
the problem is getting solved but you
know people go wow so your days just
full of problems I'm like yeah I've got
a lot of problems but but it's sort of
like how a math professor thinks of
problems right is that I think of a
great math professor who has no math
problems to solve
he's a very fat man professor and so
that's very much how I look at it
solving problems is a you know every
problem is an opportunity for innovating
and being creative and finding something
new and that's what I love to do and I
do it every day